if you were here in august
and you're sitting on the beach on a
blanket facing the sea you would think
you were in the turks and caicos
in the caribbean
the beaches have been
renamed spiedge bianca in italian which
literally means the white beaches and
you'll see you know hundreds of beach
goers flocking to that destination in
the summers
vogue italia magazine put the white
beaches on its cover i mean it's
strikingly beautiful
but this sort of caribbean like
oasis also has a dirty secret
well here's this enormous chemical plant
on the beaches of tuscany and for over a
hundred years it has been pumping
24 7 365 days a year
it's discharged straight onto the coast
and into the coastal water
it's visible on the beaches visible from
from space even so much so that it has
literally transformed the landscape the
beaches are now a stark and bright white
whereas all around that area the beaches
are sort of a more beigey color
and the question that came up is how
could that possibly
be legal that a chemical plant can just
take left over and just pump it out into
the sea and so we set out to answer that
question
you know is it okay is it is it damaging
the environment and hurting people and
the answer was actually more complicated
than we thought it would be
salve is a multinational chemicals
company based in brussels belgium it's
got a market value of far over 10
billion euros it's it's operations all
around the world
well here's a town rosignano solvay
which as the name suggests takes its
name from the company for a reason
over a hundred years ago when salve
spotted this location on the coast
of italy as infrastructure was being
built around it
it found a location which would be
suitable for its production and
literally built a town around the plant
we were talking schools we're talking a
hospital
a theater
and so this this town is literally
the embodiment of the company and its
plant in tuscany
this is a plant that makes soda ash and
ingredient in glass and it's used for
other things and essentially they take
local limestone from quarries and bring
it in and pulverize it
but essentially what has been discharged
are tiny tiny particles of limestone
mixed in seawater and that is what is
making
the beach
in part that color
their position is they take locally
quarried natural stone and they put it
through their plant and that the totally
natural sandy byproduct is just pushed
out to the sea where it does a terrific
job contributing to the environment by
helping the beach not fall victim to
erosion but the process itself of
pulverizing the stone unlocks natural
metals minerals
that are inside the stone
arsenic mercury zinc
lead
um
some of it is dissolved in the water and
some of it is still in particles and
compounds um that are part of the rock
and every year they pump the equivalent
of almost 250
000 tons
of these suspended solids directly onto
the beach and into the mediterranean
the italian government as they just have
reauthorized them with a new license
they get their stamp of approval and
and it seems there that life goes on
except
that we've been able to answer part of
the question about is it legal should it
be legal
well under italian law the one legal
standard the company has to meet
reflects the concentration of heavy
metals in the discharge what that means
is it cannot exceed
certain thresholds of milligrams per
liter of heavy metals
in its discharge
and it turns out that in 2013 it had
exceeded those concentration limits and
it never went to trial it went to a plea
bargain for polluting the beach around
the plant and of diluting
the effluent in a way that disguised the
fact that they were exceeding legal
limits such as mercury
that were going directly into the
mediterranean and this is a turning
point
solvey promised to the court that it
would somehow treat for those heavy
metals to reduce the concentrations
[Music]
the result was that
solvate has not changed how it produces
soda ash nor how it discharges
the pollutants
it has simply re-labelled
some of the plants processes
they're taking
seawater which doesn't count to their
fraction normally because it's just used
to cool all the hot stuff in the plants
not part of the production itself it's
cooling water comes in from the sea goes
out doesn't count towards their
concentration
they built something and treating for
ammonia that routed
about a third of the seawater
through a new apparatus that they built
that let them raise the denominator of
their fraction so without changing the
amount of heavy metals coming out the
bottom half
of that
got higher and higher as they put online
this new system
and now it's almost impossible to tell
if they have any heavy metals going out
the door
the company is very straightforward we
asked them have you reduced the amount
of heavy metals and they said no nothing
that we've done reduces the
concentrations increases the
concentration it's unchanged
but what they have done
is accounted for water differently
well in an email exchange with us the
company asserted that the italian court
never determined that the crimes were
committed
a really key turning point was getting
the paperwork from the court
which were able to make a special
request by citing public interest in our
status as journalists
to get the actual documentation of what
happened in court that day and it says
by how much mercury limit was exceeded
by six times over 50 percent over 30
percent over
that having these raw
numbers and then going back and seeing
it's never been in any of their
filings to shareholders they've never
described it that way they don't really
ever talk about it and seemed like it
was kind of an important moment
and so we knew that we were seeing
a difference between what was being
presented to the public being presented
to investors and the hard documentation
and that hard documentation had never
come out before
the idea that this is going on 365 days
a year with no attempt to hide it
there's no wall behind which you need to
pair there's no boundaries around this
trench that literally goes into the sea
and you know in the summers i've seen it
with my own eyes there are people
literally bathing right on the ditch
right where the discharge
enters the sea the water is a little bit
warmer perhaps that's what attracts some
of the bathers and the community that
lives around this plant has elevated
levels of diseases
showing causality always difficult
but there is a lot that the activists
have gotten their teeth into about
showing that there is an impact
activists have described the attitude
here as resignation some people don't
want to know what's you know in the air
and in the in the soil
we spoke to some of the residents most
of whom were rather indifferent to the
plant even the lady who lives right on
the footsteps of the plant sort of
shrugged her shoulders and said you know
you've got to die of something and when
we made our way to the plants entrance
well the reception there was quite
frosty
uh we came here and security at the
front gate of the plant stopped elisa
because she was taking pictures and they
threatened to call the police
and so she joked this morning that you
know be careful when the police stop you
see they don't break your cameras
sure enough when we were filming
our interview with an activist on the
beach
men in plainclothes came up behind us
and we were done flashed their badges
and wanted to see id and want to know
who we were working for you don't get
close to this plant without somebody
knowing who you are what you're doing
and
making you feel a little uncomfortable
about being here
i think the trouble with regulation is
as we found is is in part the disjointed
nature on the one hand you have the
courts they enforce the law they
prosecute on the other hand you have the
environment ministry which is now in
charge of
regulating and
allowing survey to operate a plant it
wasn't clear to us just how much
communication there was between for
example the courts and the environmental
ministry
we know that prosecutors are looking at
solvay again though it's not clear what
the basis of their investigation might
be how advanced
and who it might be focusing on
[Music]
so you've launched a pretty high profile
campaign to get the ceo of solvay
removed another important turning point
was the entry onto the scene of bluebell
an activist investor group based in
london and you know every year they pick
another target and buy one share in this
case they bought one share of solve
and they went after the company for its
for its italian plant
and what this did was create a ton of
publicity around this and raised some
really good questions and what caught
our eye was at the 2021
shareholders meeting they asked a lot of
questions about the water flowing in the
water flowing out
and they didn't get a lot of answers
they got a lot of apples and oranges
figures from the company companies
certainly didn't tell them what they
could have which was that they changed
how they account for the water starting
in 2019
what happens next is solvay is facing a
litany of challenges they're facing it
with a potential uh
prosecution in livorno courts they're
facing it with an uprising from this
activist investor
they're facing it from activists who are
energized by the fact that they somehow
had no idea that the government here in
italy was about to renew their license
for another 12 years
and that renewal there is really
important to them and staying in
business here and being viable and not
having found to have violated any laws
or have problems with disclosure they
need everything to go right for them
not just because this is you know 17 of
their global business and one that they
want to sell or dispose of but because
it could affect their stock i mean
always you can see it the fact that
they're pushing back against this
activist investor and trying to
discredit him with public statements
this is a turning point for this company
as thing stands there there are no
indications that survey intends to
change this process in this particular
location
and the change will probably have to
come from above the change will probably
have to come from policy that um is
updated to reflect the norms and
practices that um that are used as well
but it is astounding that no matter what
is being discharged the sheer volume of
it and the fact that it's affecting the
landscape is carrying on and has been
carrying on for decades
you